here are some completely mind-blowing  facts didn't knows you already know the  only time incorrectly is it spelled  incorrectly is when it's spelled  incorrectly you're stumped is always  filled with warm vomit 1/7 of your life  will be spent on a Tuesday think about  every single person who has ever drank  water will die  kisum creates one giant poop tube  between two people it's kind of romantic  all the winners of the Miss Universe  pageant have been from Earth everything  in the universe either is or is not ice  cream and finally you can go the rest of  your life without breathing don't  believe me give it a shot I'll wait  well them I hope your mind is blown